rita aus dem russischen sankt petersburg
hat spenden gesammelt und bringt sie
jungen ukrainer russen und ukrainer
umarmen sich es tut mir so leid es tut
mir so leid sagte rita immer wieder und
meinte mit putins krieg wie der studiert
in frankfurt an der oder ihre familie
aber lebt in sankt petersburg
das kann man einfach nicht beschrieben
so dass es einfach so unmenschlich was
passiert in die russische studentin ist
besorgt denn die medikamente die sie für
die ukraine gesammelt hat haben nur
einen deutschen beipackzettel
natürlich so wirkstoff kennt man aber
sie haben sicher zu sein ja soll man
wirklich das sollte hier ein op den
rasen für werber und katja aus der
ukraine ist die spendenaktion hilfe und
ablenkung von den unfassbaren
ereignissen in ihrer heimat bis zum
letzten moment habe ich gedacht dass es
nicht zu einem krieg kommt weil wir
waren immer brüder und schwester also
russland ukraine immer zusammen und ich
dachte es kommt zu keinem krieg hier im
verbindungshaus forst in frankfurt an
der oder einem wohnprojekt mit
internationalen studierenden gibt es das
wovon die ganze welt derzeit räumt ein
friedliches miteinander
das forst projekt lebt von den ideen
seiner bewohner und besucher in diesen
tagen dreht sich alles um die hilfe für
die ukraine den weg hierher findet auch
ihr sahar ingo aus dem ukrainischen
kharkiv stündlich erreichen ihn
nachrichten von seiner familie von
freunden die dort in größter gefahr sind
aber alle plätze wo ich wirklich mein
leben verbracht habe sie sind vernichtet
oder teilweise zerstört das ist
unglaublich
ratlosigkeit wie kann man am besten
helfen fragen sie sich katja will an die
grenze fahren vor ort geflüchtete
unterstützen ein krieg dauert ja nicht
im monat oder eine woche sondern er
jahrelang ich denke
im krieg noch sehr
überlegt sogar ob er in seiner heimat
fahren und selbst zur waffe greifen soll
dann habe ich darüber nachgedacht und
hat auch selbst im kino keine hinzugehen
und halte auch wirklich für mein land zu
kämpfen also ist so was sind meine
großeltern da man muss das tun also es
ist wenn es drauf ankommt dann mache ich
das auch also ich meine wir sind jetzt
hier und wir können vielleicht hier
bessere hilfe leisten als an der front
also ich meine wir haben auch gar keine
kampferfahrung zum beispiel
studenten in frankfurt an der oder
verzweifeln am krieg und auch in potsdam
macht sich der russe sergej seine
gedanken noch ist das russische
restaurant in dem er arbeitet geöffnet
doch dass sein heimatland krieg gegen
die ukraine führt ist ein schock für ihn
und wir sind freunde arbeitskollegen
auch also wir haben nie schwierigkeiten
gekommen
und was sowas also dass ich habe
gegangen die noch so eine letzte vorwurf
machen dass das puzzle benimmt den sinn
aber ich habe damit nichts zu tun ich
lebe seit 30 jahren in deutschland also
bis mir natürlich peinlich dass so was
alles
noch kommen auch in diesen tagen
touristen in die alexandrowka nirgendwo
sonst ist brandenburg russischer
erzieher die siedlung aus blockhäusern
wurde vor 200 jahren errichtet als
preußens könig seinen engsten
verbündeten zar alexander ihren wollte
tatjana ist deutsch russen und mit einem
deutschen verheiratet lange hegte sie
sympathien für putin doch nun ist er
auch für sie ein verbrecher
und
wieso nennt er ukraine die für ihren
land kämpfen als nazi als ich das gefühl
habe ich dachte ich höre nicht richtig
oder was was finanziell die beschützen
ihr land ihr kollege russland der koch
kommt aus der ukraine
täglich verfolgt er die nachrichten aus
der heimat
mein bruder ist noch in der ukraine in
iwano frankiwsk dort ist es gefährlich
denn sie haben den flughafen bombardiert
ihm wurde gesagt dass er von dort weg
gehen soll weil noch immer bomben fallen
es ist schwer für mich einzuschlafen ich
bin immer am telefon
[Musik]
russland versucht sich abzulenken doch
oft denkt er an seine freunde die jetzt
ihr leben riskieren und kämpfen müssen
tatjana hat angst um ihn
ich werde ihnen niemals niemals in die
bar verkauft in die abend und luken und
dann und dann in den sicheren tod
schicken
ich lasse nicht weggehen er bleibt bei
mir bleibt bei mir
im restaurant hoffen sie nun das nicht
mehr länger alle russen unter
generalverdacht gestellt werden so
jedenfalls hat entschieden sich auch in
der öffentlichkeit klar zur solidarität
mit der ukraine zu bekennen
zurück in frankfurt an der oder im
begegnungs zentrum forst wollen sich in
nina aus sankt petersburg wo war und ihr
aus der ukraine und die anderen mit
experten ihrer universität der viadrina
über das aktuelle geschehen austauschen
die europa universität baut seit 30
jahren brücken zwischen ost und west die
wissenschaftler sind vom kriegsausbruch
geschockt und stellen gleichzeitig fest
dass die ukraine zusammenrücken
klinische politische mission geboren
sind jetzt sind wir so einig wie früher
auch sascha aus russland will ihre
zuversicht nicht verlieren
ich hoffe dass immer mehr menschen auf
die straße gehen werden dass es wirklich
zu einem massenhaften protest wird das
die ganze stadt raus geht alles stadt in
russland dass menschen sich darüber
informieren was jetzt passiert dass sie
aufhören diesen propaganda zu glauben
was in staatlichen medien zeigt wird in
den ukrainischen farben bemalen russen
und ukrainer t shirts für die nächste
friedensdemonstration wie sie mit dem
krieg den putin führt überhaupt
weiterleben können wissen besonders die
russen hier manchmal nicht ich will das
irgendwie irgendwie einen anderen
menschen helfen wo mein land jetzt diese
unmenschliche zerstörung betreibt ja
wenn sie mit ihrer mutter in russland
telefoniert vermisst sie betroffenheit
sie habe einfach ganz normal ihr
normales leben gelebt ohne irgendwie ich
in der gedanken zu haben was überhaupt
passiert also ich will das nicht
rechtfertigen weil sie genug medien gibt
wie man sich informieren kann aber das
ding ist ich glaube menschen versuchen
das wirklich absichtlich auszublenden
weil sonst haben sie diese ausrede aber
ich wusste nicht dass es so schlimm ist
bei rita aus sankt petersburg kommen zu
den schuldgefühlen dass irland
völkermord begeht auch noch die sorgen
um die eigene ich komme aus einer
multikulti familie so meine kindheit war
in sankt petersburg irgendwie dort
ausgebrochen aber so meine verwandte ich
sind ja auch teilweise aus der ukraine
also meine mama meine oma ist
hundertprozentig ukraine ritas vater ist
russe hat verständnis für putin das
spaltet die familie als konsequenz zieht
ritas mutter nun von russland in die
ukraine
eigentlich macht schluss mit meinem
vater jetzt nicht dafür aber sondern sie
fährt jetzt meiner oma
und das nimmt also alle sachen die ich
brauchte um sie verteilt also auf sankt
petersburg für meinen vater eigentlich
weil was er gesagt hat ich weiß einfach
wie kann es sein dass wir eine familie
sind die meinungen gehen so
so unterschieden sich
sascha kennt das schon 2014 hat sie
wegen der annexion der krim mit ihrem
vater gebrochen sie wollte unbedingt in
die ukraine zu einem schulischen
austauschprojekt er hat versucht auf
mich druck auszuüben ich bin da
hingefahren groß ist das nicht holte
weil es ist mein leben ist meine
entscheidung
und dagegen können wir keinen kontakt
tatsächlich
gräben überwinden und gemeinsam nach
vorne blicken das wollen sie hier in
frankfurt an der oder denn europa war
lange genug geteilt